[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green you know I bet that
you'll be fine without a pre-recording I
think so are we live
yeah I hope so hey everybody my name is
Joshua fields Milburn I'm Ryan Nicodemus
and together we are the minimalist
welcome to a special edition of ask of a
minimalist live we're here to answer
your questions so if you have questions
now's a good time to start typing them
out our our good friend and colleague
podcast Sean is over on the other side
of the room and he is he is furiously
writing down your questions and
aggregating them and he's gonna curate a
nice list and what we're gonna do is do
our best to to give you pithy answers to
to all of your questions so Sean go
ahead and start taking down those
questions if you don't mind and in the
meantime Ryan will do his tap dancing
routine yes what do you've been up to
lately man you went to LA recently right
I did go to LA recently it was
outstanding we're both back here in
Missoula Montana right now Ryan you were
just in Florida just got back I was in
Dayton and LA and I tried to go to
Florida with you but then my plane was
canceled due to weather and there's a
lot of snow in Montana right now and so
instead I spent Christmas spent the
holidays here with Becks and we had a
low-key Christmas listen to a lot of
Tribe Called Quest and and didn't do
much but hang around the house and enjoy
each other's company well that's nice
indeed I'll tell you when we were
landing in Missoula from we were flying
in from Salt Lake City on our trip back
from from Tampa Florida that runway was
Lake it wasn't covered in snow but it
had snow on it and I'm like how like how
in the world can you land an airplane
with a little bit sure enough man Here I
am
there's no mishaps but it was pretty
crazy
Sean do we have any questions that are
ready for us
yes actually quite a few so here's what
how can a minimalist life effect of
healthy mental state hmm how can the
minimalist life affect a healthy mental
stable let's start by talking about what
minimalism is minimalism has to do with
getting rid of the excess stuff in our
lives that's really the initial bite at
the Apple because we believe that your
material possessions are a physical
manifestation of what's going on inside
you so if you have a lot of external
clutter then it's likely that you have a
lot of internal clutter we can call that
emotional clutter we can call it
spiritual clutter we can call that
mental clutter but it's all stuff that's
going on inside so by being able to deal
with what's going on outside it helps us
be more aware of that internal clutter
and start to be able to deal with that
once we've let go of that which is is
superfluous externally and I like to
think of dealing with the external
clutter allows us to deal with the
internal clutter so long term we can
deal with the eternal clutter the sort
of existential clutter of our lives yeah
I think for me man minimalism helps me
with that impulse it's like I will see
the new iPhone or I'll see you know a
new TV or a new car like you know I
still got the 2004 Toyota Corolla mmm we
call it the tour bus yes yes and dude
this winter has just been miserable with
it Lake uh-huh it's the first winner
I've been driving this car well I'm
sorry it's the fourth winter that I've
been driving into Missoula it's the
first time that I have like really just
felt like oh my god I need to get a
four-wheel drive vehicle uh-huh
so I actually started like pricing out
you know some like rock fours and you
know some other like fairly reasonably
priced four by fours huh and at the end
of the day like I'm looking at you know
spending tens not tens of thousands of
dollars but 10,000 bucks let's say you
know I might be able to put $5,000 down
on it and then have like a $5,000 loan
huh but I don't want to like you know
minimalism helps me it helps me stop and
think like do I want to have that even
if it's just a hundred dollar pay
month like do I want to be beholden to
that 100 dollar payment a month for the
next 5 years right so you know instead
of like going out and getting a
brand-new 4x4 where I went out and I
spent 500 bucks on some snow tires and
they don't they're not perfect like as
you saw me getting out of the parking
lot the other day but that was like
that's the only trouble I've had with
them sure so it's like you know it's
these little one offs where I had
trouble and yeah sure and like yeah find
a 4x4 I'd just be able to like go up and
over everything and be fine not a little
ways though and if people go back to if
you for those of you so we're by the way
for everyone who's listening I don't
know what platform you're on we're on
YouTube live right now and we're
answering questions on on YouTube live
we're also answered some questions from
our social media feeds whether it's
Twitter and Instagram at the minimalist
or facebook.com slash the minimalist
we'll have answer some questions from
there as well but if those of you who
listen to our podcasts you you can go
back to the holiday episode we did and I
have a four-wheel-drive vehicle I have a
Toyota 4runner and I have it
specifically because we live in Montana
if I lived in Los Angeles I wouldn't
have the same vehicle I don't think it
makes sense to have here but but the
point being is I you can still you can
still get hurt yes I mean you hit ice it
doesn't matter what you're driving in
once you hit ice it's gonna slide yeah
yeah but you know like being able to
stop and really deliberate whether or
not this 4x4 is going to add more value
than that you know the $100 I would save
a month
it helps me yeah it helped me to choose
the snow tires and said but I guess what
I'm really getting at is is like anytime
we take on a monthly payment that's
gonna fill up mental space so yeah
certainly if we make good decisions with
all of our resources you know we're
talking about money right now but you
know even with our time and our
attention I think people forsake those
as resources because they think it's
yeah this infinite we all have time we
all have attention but it's your most
precious resource when you really think
about it yeah so like just being able to
ask those questions and kind of stop
myself from just acting on that impulse
and really getting down to that that
question that we always talk about man
is the
going to add value to your life it keeps
that mental space freed up and certainly
keeps me you know more stress free I
mean yeah at like the the Ryan Nicodemus
of yesteryear would have just like went
and got a loan because I don't have a
payment right now so like the 25 year
old Ryan kid Dimas what he needed a
payment I don't have a payment I got
plenty of room for payments in my life
so yes certainly minimalism does help
clear the mind but you know not just
with with financial aspects but even
meditation like that's a very mindful
practice I wish I could say that we
invented meditation but that's been
around forever it's certainly a simple
approach to clearing clearing the mental
clutter but yeah I mean that certainly
helps a lot too yeah for sure and in our
documentary so so for those of you who
haven't seen it yet our film is called
minimalism a documentary about the
important things it just came out on
Netflix and so a lot of you have seen it
on Netflix or if you don't have Netflix
you can see it on iTunes or worldwide on
Vimeo you can check it out there there's
a whole mindfulness section in there we
have Sam Harris and Dan Harris both of
whom were not related to each other but
both of whom wrote really great books
about clearing mental clutter dan
Harris's book is probably my favorite
book on the subject is it's very
approachable it's uh it's called Tim
person happier and I think the subtitle
is a fidgety skeptics guide to
meditation or mindfulness or whatever
but it's a whole sort of memoir and it's
very well really good
so Tim person happier is a great way to
woohoo out of it man it absolutely does
yeah he has his good podcast as well
called also called 10% happier and then
Sam Harris his book waking up he also
has a podcast called waking up and
another thing that I would add in there
another book that I would recommend to
folks is Rob Bell wrote a book called
how to be here and it's about what the
title is yeah how do you be present
there's a guy who sent me this it's the
most ingenious idea so for the longest I
never wore a watch but ever since I've
been doing all these back exercises from
my back I need a timer so I have a
little eBay watch that I have here and
this guy sent sent me a link they're
doing a Kickstarter campaign I think
it's called the now watch hmm you know W
I think is what it's called I don't know
anything about it I'm not
endorsing it necessarily but I thought
it was interesting it's a watch it's
like a timepiece it's a band and a
normal watch except you look at the face
and all it says is now I love it and
it's always now an interesting concept
yeah so you can either be a total jerk
with that a pretentious jerk someone
walks up what time is it hey what time
is it it's right now you're gonna sound
like you just like the drugs or
something
yeah so but it's a I think it's a nice
reminder if you are looking for to
retrain yourself to be be in the present
moment remember what time is it it's
always right now and so those are some
good recommendations for you to dive
into Sean what's our next question well
first off you can always see Josh and I
store schedule at the minimalists
dot-com forward slash tour we don't have
any upcoming stops I don't like that now
unless you've added something last
couple weeks um we don't have any
upcoming stops right now but certainly
we do have some plans for 2017 we're
really excited about just going out and
sharing some some new ideas about some
things we've been talking about yeah if
you're on our email list that's the best
way to stay informed of new cities we're
coming to so you just go to the
minimalists comm enter your email
address at the top we will never ever
send you an advertisement advertisement
suck we think spam email suck so we'll
never do that and if you are on our
email list make sure that you go
sometimes it'll get thrown into the spam
folder or the promotions tab just move
it over into your inbox you do that one
or two times and it will make sure that
we continue to show up in your inbox and
we'll only send you things that we think
will add value to your life so will we
hit the road again
so let's go back so Ryan I tend to focus
on one thing a year sometimes two so if
you go back and look at the last few
years 2014 we hit the road we donated
basically 10 months of our lives we did
119 free events in 100 cities 8
different countries we brought our book
called everything that remains it's a
memoir about the five years of our life
about the Train
dition from from the suit-and-tie
corporate guys - this lifestyle of
minimalism and eventually becoming the
minimalist which by the way that book is
free right now if you go to our website
the minimalist calm slash merry as in
Merry Christmas that's our Christmas
gifts to you you can get a free copy of
everything that remains and so I hope
you enjoy that I hope you find some
value and if you do please rate it
review it whatever or pass it on to
someone else who can give value from it
but we donated that year of our lives
with 119 free events to try to spread a
message we really believe in and then
2015 it was a year of contribution we
built three clean water wells in Malawi
and with the help of you all people from
our audience we got people to to
contribute to that as well so we've
built three clean water wells which
provided water to twelve hundred and
fifty people so thank you all if you
have you helped out with that we also
built a elementary school out in Laos
and Ryan you you went out to the grand
opening of that earlier this year the
awesome in interacting with all these
elementary school kids sixty-six of them
in total yeah and and I mean they had it
was like a shack pretty much before them
and yeah yeah the old school was like it
was literally a shack with mud floors
and dirt floors every time it rained cuz
there were holes in the ceiling like it
would make mud on the floor so like
they'd have to cancel school mhm and
then it was two classrooms in this shack
with a wall that was like four foot high
dividing the classrooms so like the
teachers were constantly over talking
each other it was it was unbelievable
they unbelievably like yeah just a shack
that's a good way to a good way to
describe it they may do with the
resources they have but I didn't have
many resources but grateful to be able
to provide those resources and
contribute if you have been with our
work for a while you know Ryan and I
think the meaning of life is growth in
contribution and so all these things
we're doing we do want to add value to
other people's lives you want to
contribute beyond ourselves in a
meaningful way but that also helps us
grow and the more we grow the more we
have to give last year we also so in
addition to that we funded a high school
for an entire year in Kenya we did an
orphanage in Honduras with our friend
Joshua Becker and the hope effect which
is the charity the not the nonprofit
that he said
and I was able to build an orphanage
there and and Honduras we also had some
domestic charities that we contributed
to and I always personally like to give
to organizations from give well.org the
against malaria foundation is where I'm
currently sending as much money as I can
in terms of my my charitable giving and
so you can find that at giveWell org and
then this year our main focus was create
a focus create a focus at least was to
get this documentary out and to in front
of more people and so Ryan and I spent
the last three years with our good
friend Matt dia Vela who was a very
talented director and we filmed this
documentary and it's called minimalism
and we spent this year getting in front
of people because most of you know who
are creators of something part of the
creative process is finishing the the
artifact that you're trying to finish
whether it's a book or a blog post or a
movie or a short film or a YouTube video
you want to finish that thing but then
the second thing is how can you
effectively and efficiently get that in
front of more people right because
that's part of the artistic process the
creative process is communication
otherwise it's just an expression which
is like journaling but you want to get
it in front of more people and so we
worked all year of getting in this movie
into in front of more people learned a
lot of lessons had quite a few failures
along the way but the film came out in
about 400 theaters this this summer
across the United States and Canada and
Australia and a couple one-off events
and in different countries you Ryan you
were in Ireland recently to screen the
film and so we we found different ways
to get this message in front of people
and I'll tell you it sounds really
impressive to tell you this and I'm
proud to say that minimalism is the
number one indie documentary of 2016 in
terms of theatrical releases it still
sounds weird to me man it sounds really
weird but I'll tell you there was a huge
failure and when I say that to people
they're like what do you mean it was a
failure it's the number 1 indie
documentary and the reason I say that is
it it didn't reach as many people the
summer in theatres because it's much
harder to get people to come out to
theatres and see the film than it is to
put it up online
and what I learned from that is I would
probably not do a wide theatrical
release like that again it's not this
way people are viewing movies anymore
yeah because it's not as simple as like
great we have a documentary now it's out
in theatres I mean there's a lot of
backdoor work or you know behind the
scene processes so forth and so on that
yeah it's just it went about 50 percent
smooth and fifty percent insane and the
most value people are getting out of it
is like Josh said the downloadable
version of it and now it's on Netflix
but the theatrical release I would say
had the least impact out of everything
we've done it's not that people didn't
get value from it right who showed up
certainly did the vast majority did a
tour with that as well so we went to 15
different cities and and did a live
version of our pot of the minimalist
podcast and and found ways to to add
value in a different way and I really
enjoyed that process but the reason I
call it a failure is it's not a real
failure because we learned from it and
I'm willing to take action and change
what we did so that going forward I
wouldn't do the same thing it's only a
failure if like we did minimalism part 2
and we did the same exact thing well
let's go to theaters again no we already
tried that and while it was successful
in one sense there are so many other
people who have a say in the decision
making process when you have a
distributor and you go through all these
these other avenues and and Ryan and I
are pretty much do-it-yourself kind of
guys and and relying on on other
entities to make these decisions for you
makes it quite difficult and then of
course if they do something wrong it
makes us look bad as well and so there
are times where theaters we're having
issues with the film or or whatever and
we just didn't have that the same level
of control that we like to have of over
our creation and getting out to the
world but learning from that we
eventually put out online we put out on
Vimeo with six hours of additional bonus
content which you can still find there
on Vimeo and it's available worldwide
there I would have done that much sooner
because that's the other thing if the
film was in you know three or four or
five countries in theaters that means is
195 other countries it's not available
in right now and and so even with the
Netflix release we didn't really have
any say within a Netflix release it's
available in United States Canada
Australia New Zealand the UK and Ireland
and that's it on Netflix not our
decision if I could say make it
available worldwide on Netflix and I
would encourage them to do that but on
Vimeo and it give us the opportunity to
say okay it's not available in your
country here's the way you can find it
still and and hopefully get some value
in it and pass it on pass it on to other
folks so learning the lesson from that
that was our year this year was getting
that out into the world and so this is a
very long answer to get to the stance of
your question but what's up for 2017 we
are getting back to basics for the first
time we ride and I record a podcast
about this it'll be out relatively soon
it's just called basics and there's an
essay going up at our website at the
minimalists comm it's called back to
basics as well and we're really
refocusing on creating now that this
creation that we have is out in the
world and we have three books that are
out there that are on radically
different
well not different subjects but
radically different approaches we have a
how-to book a y2 book and a what to book
and now how do we get back to creating
the things that we find most meaningful
and so we're getting back to to our
foundation which is writing that's the
first thing the second thing is
podcasting because that's the mechanism
that we still have the room for the most
improvement where we're growing
immensely by by doing the podcast with
folks and the third thing we want to do
once my health health improves for those
of you been here for a while know that
I've been dealing with some health
issues with with my back but also with
my gut microbiome I've had a few liver
and kidney issues I won't go into detail
on that you can go back and listen to
podcast number 30 if you want to hear
about it but basically we want to hit
the road again we Ryan I have these six
simple ideas we'd like to take on the
road and instead of doing the really big
crowds we've done in the past we want to
do really intimate crowds these intimate
spaces like I like art spaces galleries
and small the tiny theater independent
theaters yeah yeah in a place that we
can work out these these ideas in front
of people and so that that's our
intention is to do that bring some ideas
on the road and so will we come to your
city
yeah probably make sure you're on our
mailing list if you want to be kept
rest of our new tour dates if and when
they pop up and then of course we do
speaking gigs from time to time so if
you have a organization or a a
conference or anything that you know
anyone who wants to bring the
minimalists out you can find all the
details to that at the minimalists comm
slash speaking we'd love to to come out
and present some minimalist ideas to
your organization Shaun do have any more
questions what else we got
yes viewers here have tried and failed
[Music]
so how do you maintain minimalism after
you've minimized I got one word for you
and I'll try to expand on that one word
is leverage you need leverage so so
professional organizers know this really
well so you mentioned the calamari
method the life-changing magic of
tidying up is the book she wrote and and
I think quite often the amateurs like me
and Ryan we're total amateurs when it
comes to this stuff we had to find
mechanisms to get the leverage we need
because we all know how to declutter our
closets right right that part is easy I
know how now don't get me wrong I think
many professional organizers they have
very useful tips and tricks that will
help you through that how-to phase very
rarely though do Ryan and I write about
the how-to side of things the
decluttering side because we are much
more interested in the y2 so ask
yourself a question how might your life
be better with less that is a question
we set out to answer when we first
started simplifying our lives because it
helped me identify what the benefits of
minimalism are now for me it was
regaining control of my finances or
maybe my health or my relationships for
other people it's about creativity it's
about spending more time with their
family it's about the environmental
impact that they have ask yourself that
question how my life be better with less
and you'll be surprised with the answers
you get if you keep digging further down
because it's not just about removing the
stuff from your life you can rent a
dumpster
and be miserable because you've thrown
all your stuff in it and now you've
removed all the pacifiers from your life
and it's really about moving forward
with the best things that augment your
experience of life yeah I mean I think
the only thing I would add to that is
like you've gotta maintain good habits I
mean that is that's what it comes down
to that question of does this add value
to my life it's redundant when you ask
it every single day but it's important
that you ask it every single day every
time you make a purchase every time you
go out to spend a dollar every time
you're bringing in a new relationship
and your life you've got to be able to
ask that question so I would say if
you're someone who has started these
great habits and fell off like get back
on the bandwagon there and don't do
everything at once I mean let's say you
know you were great at asking how you
know does this thing add value to my
life you're great with a 2020 ROI you're
great with the 90 90 90 90 rule and you
could expend what those are in a second
sure but you know and then you you're
not using those rules anymore implement
those back in your life but do it one at
a time I mean you know it's quite often
that we will start some really good
habits like for me for example I've been
working out regularly I've been eating
well for you know for the last year so I
have just been on vacation on fuller for
a week kind of fell off the bandwagon a
little bit when I came back it's not
like I'm gonna like just hop back on
every single thing but I'm gonna start
working out like I'm just gonna start
there and then I know that it will
follow and since it's been such a short
gap I know that I will pick that stuff
pretty easily but I guess but my my my
advice is is yes start with the good
habits but choose one good habit at a
time and then once you feel like you've
got that under control try to layer some
other things on yeah and if you have bad
habits it's not about simply getting rid
of the bad habits but it's about
replacing those bad habits with good
habits and so when we think about habits
every habit that we have has a trigger
so let's think about a bad habit for a
minute let's think about smoking people
who are smokers they will often have
instant triggers I wake up in the
morning gotta have a cigarette right
that that's the trigger or I just
finished a great meal now I have to have
a cigarette I'm gonna have a cup of
coffee nothing better than a cup of
coffee with a cigarette and so there
were all these triggers well how can you
take those same triggers instead of
triggering that that bad habit how can
you convert that into triggering a good
an example I will give you when I was
writing everything that remains Ryan and
I we moved into this cabin in the middle
of nowhere and we had this pull-up bar
at the bottom of our stairs and I would
every time I came downstairs from a
break from writing my I would do six
pull-ups and I can do six poles
relatively easily that wasn't the
problem
the thing is instead of just going
coming downstairs to get something to
eat which was my initial trigger I'm
gonna go downstairs I might as well raid
the fridge now well instead of doing
that I'm gonna walk underneath this
pull-up bar I might as well go ahead and
do the six-pulse I I used that same
trigger of coming down the stairs to
start doing pull-ups and pretty soon
before I knew it I was doing 6080
pull-ups a day because I would do six at
a time every time I came down the stairs
from from this little writing break that
I was taking and so identify what your
triggers are and then figure out what
bad habit you in replace with the good
habits and I totally agree with Ryan
start with one thing and then you can
build on top of that that foundation you
can build new good empowering habits
that will enable you to to live a more
intentional life overall
so just to expand expound on the 20/20
rule for those of you who don't know
20/20 rule is basically you can get
anything you want for less than $20 in
less than 20 minutes this is Josh the
knives just in case rule our theory is
as it works 99% of the time I'm sure
there's something out there you got to
have just in case it's worked for Josh
and I a 100% of the time when we lived
in the cabin in the middle of nowhere
population 870 with that 2020 rule
worked really really well so if you're
someone who's holding onto a bunch of
just incase items yeah start with that
rule that to start getting start getting
rid of stuff the 9090 rule basically if
you have an object you haven't used in
the last 90 days you'd be honest with
yourself as you if you ask yourself if
you're gonna use it in the next 90 days
and the answer is no to get rid of it
it's it's that covers pretty much all
seasons um again our theory is is it
works 99% at a time but that's just said
it works the majority of the time but
yeah incorporating habits like that will
help you maintain but you gotta stick to
those habits it's like any other
any other habits you bring into your
life like I said with working out like
once you stop well then guess what
you're going to start to get unhealthy
again yeah and one of the things I've
really found empowering allowed me to to
let go of many of the things I was
holding on to it's called the tin tin
material possessions theory and you take
a piece of paper write down the 10 most
expensive things you've you've purchased
in the last decade last 10 years and
then you flip the piece of paper over
and write down the 10 most meaningful
experience of the last 10 years and then
you just sort of scratch your head and
wonder why none of the items on either
side of the list match and it gave me
information to let go of many of the
things I thought yeah I had to hold on
to because of some cost and well it's a
very expensive thing or whatever no I
can sell it I can do something else with
it because it hasn't brought me the joy
I thought it was going to bring me just
in case thoughts along with the just in
case items yes so let's talk about we'll
go back to just the case items again so
Ryan and I when we were on our very
first tour five years ago we were you
we've been the minimalist for one year
our first book which is called
minimalism live a meaningful life it's
about the five values we uncover it
after jettison our our excess stuff we
figured out that here are the things
were supposed to hear the five things
are supposed to focus on we went on a
first tour we were down in st.
Petersburg Florida which is where
minimalism sort of started for me and
because my mother was living down there
when she passed away and we got down
there after simplifying our lives like
we were the minimalists right and we
were drugged we drove down there in our
tour bus which is Ryan's Toyota Corolla
and we finally got that it popped open
the trunk and I'm like what are we doing
Ryan just looks over he goes we're such
hypocrites there were two soup
cases full stuff there was a garment bag
in case I needed a suit for something
apparently and then there were two sort
of carry-on bags now keeping my carry-on
in your car we weren't getting on an
airplane going anywhere that we were
carrying on in the car so we had all
this sort of superfluous stuff we packed
with us why just in case the three most
dangerous words in the English language
and we realized that we had just packed
so many things but we thought we might
need in some hypothetical tour that we
were going on I had three pairs of swim
trunks oh I'm gonna be in Florida might
as well pack an extra pair of swim
trunks
but what if both of them get dirty I
might as well pick my my third pair of
swimming truck and I'm like and then
we're down there I'm like why do I even
own three pairs of swimming trunks that
doesn't even make any sense to me well
the answer is just in case and so we
made this resolution together that for
the rest of the tour when we got back
and we went out in these little legs
we'd go out three or four or five cities
at a time for the rest of the tour we're
not gonna pack any just in case on us
and that's where that 2020 rule came
from because we thought you know what we
can replace anything that we really need
just in case for less than twenty
dollars in less than 20 minutes from
where we are the cool thing is that's
held up 100% of the time for us and when
I got back home it actually gave me
permission to let go of tens of
thousands of other items because I knew
that we never really had to implement
that rule between the two of us over the
last five years we've had to use that
rule five times total
yeah I'd replace a pair of scissors I on
a cloud replace a pair of swimming
trunks and so yeah I used to keep a
just-in-case toothbrush in my toiletry
bag and I forgot my toothbrush and had
to go buy a toothbrush yeah so there
there you go so far and so and all those
things are for less than $20 I think
yeah these in many cases and the cool
thing is it's not a rule I've had to use
a hundred times it'd be a terrible rule
if I've had to use the Justin case for a
thousand times and spent twenty thousand
dollars I'm just in case I know between
the two of us we've had to spend a
hundred dollars in the last five years
on just in case on that hundred dollars
or fit my my $50 contribution
is well worth the peace of mind so that
gets back to the question the peace of
mind that we've gotten over the last
five years of being willing to let go of
those Justin Kazon is because truth be
told the vast majority of those just in
case items they are just in the way yeah
and you know this one point where I
realize that it let's say I had ten
thousand just in case items I was
holding on to and somehow they were like
nicely neatly organized and I was able
to justify them somehow at the end of
the day there are an exponential amount
of other items I don't have that I might
need in some non-existent
or existence you know hypothetical
future and it's it's uh it's really
really o destabilizing when you hold on
to all those things I just remember junk
drawers full of stuff so it wasn't well
organized but I had Junkers and all
these just in case items and you know
going back to the point in that question
that Sean just threw at us with the
items that you hold on to in case
another item breaks so let's just do
this with like a USB cable for example I
used to have like drawers fully USB
cables just in case I needed them now if
I was to hold on just one USB cable and
let's say it broke and I'm like oh man I
really wish I had that old USB cable
there's probably a better model there's
probably a better quality product that I
can get at this point
if than me holding on to one that is ten
or fifteen years old and doesn't have
you know it's not as strong or whatever
I mean I don't that's a good example or
not but but my point is is like if
you're holding on to just incase items
to replace something when it breaks
you're replacing it with an older model
when there's there's gonna be something
newer out there anyway so I would say if
you have just in case items now don't
just go throw them away and fill the
landfill go donate and find someone else
who can use them right now and get value
out of them instead of them just sitting
around your house yeah I totally agree
and you know what what I think with that
is because if you let go of it you're
letting go is a form of contribution but
just because you don't get value in
something that doesn't mean that someone
else won't you know there are are plenty
of thrift shops who will reallocate your
goods for you so it's not like you have
to go find well this USB charger that I
had
I need to go find the appropriate person
to give this to no let an aggregator do
that for you so in missoula vessels are
called donation warehouse they even come
pick stuff up for you other place of
goodwill look for your local charity
organization there's a website called
donation town I think it's donation town
org you can find the sort of charities
that will often come pick your stuff up
for you and reallocate it find someone
else who will get value from that stuff
shall we go yeah I mean so the question
is is when we buy something are we aware
of the environmental impacts are we
aware of the sustainability the the
corporations ethics when we look towards
certain brand names yeah there are there
are certain brands that I avoid like
Walmart I I will go there if I
absolutely have to I'll give you an
example
I am Mariah My partner and I we are
helping out a refugee family they just
moved to Missoula Montana like less than
two months ago and they are given a very
little bit of a stipend for food a
little bit of a stipend for you know
other necessities
Walmart happens to have like the
cheapest produce and like what they
needed so yeah like we went there and
got the produce that they needed in the
groceries that they needed so yes like
in those situations I will and one-offs
go or like let's say Walmart's the only
thing that's open on Christmas Day and
like I got to go get my insulin you know
and it's the only place I can go get it
I mean there are gonna be these one-offs
but yeah certainly try to yeah purchase
responsibly I think I think that the way
we vote now is with our dollar that's
like the strongest vote we have and yeah
certainly I will avoid places that don't
have good ethics I'm trying to think
what else do I avoid I go out on my way
to purchase um you know I think it's
interesting with the so being a
minimalist the the first thing you
notice is that if you consume less not
only do you produce less waste but and
this is tautological a little bit if you
consume less you actually buy less
you're buying fewer things right and and
so if I if I am going to make a purchase
because I'm buying far fewer things than
I did once upon a time those those
purchases are inherently more
intentional because I don't want to have
to repurchase the thing six months from
now a year from now because it was poor
quality or or whatever and so when I do
bring something into my life it is with
a lot more intention than I ever did
before and so Ryan you mentioned a
question earlier about does this thing
add value to my life now when I first
started embracing minimalism I asked
that question a lot in fact I asked it
so frequently it became less of an
intellectual exercise and more of this
emotion that I got this emotional
exercise of you know what this has had
value because I asked it so much as I
was letting go of these things the
average American household has 300
thousand items of it so I had to ask
this question a lot of times does this
add value to my life does this have
value to my life and as I asked that
over and over and over it no longer
became me asking it it was me feeling
does this add value to my life and I
know that sounds we were especially for
a guy who's so analytical for me but it
becomes an incantation of sorts and that
incantation then bled over to the new
things I brought into my life is this
going to actually add value to my life
and if it's a big purchase I tend to put
it off for at least 30 days so I can
contemplate it and I make sure so a big
purchase for me is generally anything
over 250 dollars I'm gonna put it off
for up for about a month if I can and
unless there's an emergency if a water
heater breaks or something why just call
my landlord water heater breaks but you
get the point that there are exceptions
to that rule but for the most part any
large purchase can I afford it
meaning monetarily but then can I afford
the embedded costs it's I gotta take all
this time to clean the thing to put gas
in the thing the change of things oil to
wash the thing to dry the thing to
recharge the thing and then of course
it's going to take up my time and my
attention can I afford all those other
costs that maybe aren't embedded in the
price tag and I have to be honest with
myself and that's gonna help me
determine whether or not it's going to
add value to my life and
yes when I'm doing research I will try
to source my things from the most
ethical companies you know the the shirt
I'm wearing right now and I know the
shirt you're wearing right now both made
in America now just because something is
made in America doesn't mean it's
inherently the best thing either you you
can treat your employees like crap even
though they're Americans or you can
treat your employees great even though
they're overseas so it's not inherently
good or good or evil or it's not binary
it's not saying yes or no to these
things it's about being intentional with
the information that we have in front of
us when we're consuming but of course if
we buy less stuff then we have to be
more intentional about the things we
continue to bring into our lives shall
what else we got their site they have a
great message but it seems like no one's
listening
hmm well there are a few tips that I
always give to people when they're
asking about growing a website or
growing a blog or whatever it may be the
first and foremost tip I give is you
have to be able to add value that is the
only reason why people come to Josh and
i's website it's because they get some
type of value out of it do all seven
billion people in the world get value
out of it no but enough to to where we
have a decent readership which is great
the other thing too is Josh and I the
second tip is you know put forth your
best work Josh and I go out of our way
to make sure that you know when we post
an essay or if we're doing a redesign to
the website or with the documentary even
we make sure that it's the absolute best
quality that we can put out there we
never force a quantity over quality it
has it has to look good it has to look
the best and you know what when Josh and
I look at stuff from five years ago you
know sometimes we laugh at ourselves
like wow like we can't believe we put
this out but at the time that was the
absolute best that we could do the third
thing is is be consistent like if you if
you have an essay one day that talks
about you know global warming and then
the next essay you're talking about a
you know a pro-hillary
host I mean there isn't there isn't a
there's there's not congruence there I
think that's a decent example there but
you just don't want to be all over at
least be consistent when people go to
the minimalists comm they know what
they're gonna get they're gonna get a
perspective they're gonna get either you
know my recipe or Josh's recipe and
they're gonna be able to tweeze
ingredients out of it when it comes to
our lifestyle when it comes to
minimalism when it comes to living a
simple life you know I have seen it time
and time again where I have friends who
will have a blog post go viral let's say
they get you know 5 million I've
literally seen this we look at 5 million
hits in a day when they're used to you
know getting maybe 5,000 hits a month
but then guess what the next month
they're only gaining 5,000 hits because
that one blog posts them went viral
there's nothing else on their website
like that like that blog post went viral
so consistency put forth your best work
add value and then you know the fourth
one be unique you know find find
something a spin on something that no
one else has out there that you can put
on the message you're trying to produce
like what Josh and I you know I I didn't
see hindsight I can see why we were able
to grow a readership in this blogosphere
of people there are thousands and
thousands of blogs on minimalism and
when Josh and I one thing that helped us
rise to the top I guess is the fact that
we had this unique perspective like
we're two best friends like we're kind
of you know journeying life together
we're learning lessons with each other
and there wasn't another perspective out
there so if you can be unique by far be
unique because people they want to see a
unique perspective that's the word and
then the the I just started this fifth
one okay but now I forgot it though be
unique and if I remember you go I
remember I think it was Gandhi who said
be the blog you want to see in the world
he said it on Twitter I'm pretty sure
yeah yeah or was it
be the podcast you want to see in the
world I anyway it was interesting for me
I I spent most of my 20s writing
literary fiction because I didn't have a
very interesting life to to write about
and I so I teach a writing class over at
how to write better org and one of the
things that I tell my writing students
is that you are simultaneously more
interesting and less interesting than
you think you are and what does that
mean well the reason I write or create
something so pod consider you know my
primary form of creativity to be writing
but also podcasting is very similar and
I do it for the same reasons I want to
express myself and I want to communicate
with other people you have to have both
perspectives if you don't if you just
have the expressive piece it's like
journaling and that means you think
you're more interested in you actually
are but if you're just communicating
like a math textbook is then it is not
going to be interesting to create I
don't think you know you don't feel
compelled to go on a beach and start
reading a calculus textbook unless
you're someone who is is a little
strange and if so I applaud you for that
I love calculus yeah but I I really do
yeah I know you do but you're probably
not at the beach with the textbook you
know that's sure and and so you you love
the act of it and the book is is a
communication tool and so I think a good
blow of a good podcast a good whatever
does it marries the two equally you can
express yourself and your unique
perspective as you say but you also
realized you're communicating with other
people and the last thing that I'll say
is go back and listen to our podcast
episode number 42 it's about creating
and I gave 12 different tips for how
people can grow their audience how we
did it specifically and if you're
looking to start a blog the other thing
that I'll point you towards go to the
minimalists comm slash blog it's exactly
the recipe that we use because we
couldn't even spell HTML and the on set
here and we finally figure out how to
cobble a website together and in time we
grew our traffic there was nothing that
was viral necessarily it was a slow burn
and allowed us to grow
slowly incrementally over these last six
years I remembered I got two of them
actually okay to number five a no FB
number five a and number five B be
genuine like people will sniff out if
you're not genuine it is it is it's easy
in one blog post to maybe you know fake
who you are and fake it on Instagram and
Facebook but eventually the larger you
grow people are going to be able to see
people who are inauthentic so be genuine
upfront because it'll bite you later for
sure the other thing I had was be an
expert I almost forgot it but then I
remembered be an expert like what are
you an expert in you know I love
calculus but I'm not gonna start a blog
about about calculus because I'm not an
expert in that like when I think of you
know what were what did Josh and I start
the minimalist on like how are we
experts right from the beginning well we
were to do to like lived that corporate
life we were two guys who dope head
first put in the hours bought everything
we wanted to do and we realize like wow
this is not what we want and here's why
and people looked at us as experts
because well we had that perspective
people could look up to us and know that
we had a good handle on what it was like
to have to be in that world and what it
was like to leave you've ever really
good point there with the expertise we
were in a weird way we were experts of
discontent yes that's what a great book
title of patent-pending I just did try
to stop me you know I
we were experts in discontent and we we
turned our lives around so we weren't
experts in this this broad sort of
minimalism like and even now I were
certainly not experts in minimalist
literature like yeah I enjoy Jay
McInerney and Lorrie Moore and Bret
Easton Ellis's literature but I'm not an
expert in Raymond Carver's studies or
whatever minimalist architecture
minimalist music like those are
different types of minimalism they're
getting down to what is essential in
those different crafts those different
art forms but we were experts of
discontent yeah and and then we turned
our lives around so we were experts in
turning around the discontent and
finding meaning and so back to Ryan's
plan when we were writing
stuff on the website we're constantly
finding ways to loop in the meaning so
when Ryan I wrote about those five
values in our life everything that we we
talk about now tends to lead back to our
five core values or higher order values
of health relationships creativity or
even call passion growth and
contribution when ever ends many of the
things we talk or write about they cover
more than one of those topics and and
that that's sort of the beacon by which
we steer the ship Sean what else we got
here we can do one or two more know me
first
I don't journal regularly but I do
journal see Mariah journals she started
this I don't know a couple months ago
and I have been kind of catching on like
if I'm not so tired that I just focus
she'll sit in bed and write and if I'm
really tired I'll just fall asleep but
sometimes I'm not and instead of like
going to my phone and looking at
Facebook or YouTube videos or whatever I
will pull out my phone and I will
journal on my iPhone and I literally
have a note right now that's probably 50
pages long it just starts with date and
then my thoughts and then next date
thoughts and it's just a note that I
keep on my iPhone it's very similar to
seems like it's very similar to
gratitude journaling which yeah which
I've done before I've done the five
minute journal before I don't have a
journal practice regularly and if you're
asking what tools we use I'll tell you
this I don't really care like I I'm less
concerned I don't care what pencils
Stephen King used to to pin his last
book these pencils to pin books anyway
but if you're really interested there's
some software programs I use so I
actually used the memo pad a lot to
write on now memo pad on the computer so
I have oh yeah a MacBook and I
of an iPhone and it syncs up between the
two of them and I have an infinite
number of notes every I have a list of
200 300 different blog post ideas for
different essays and and different lists
just different thing as soon as idea
comes to me you better believe it's
getting put down in that memo pad in
terms of I write a lot of things
longhand as well so you can for those of
you watching this on youtube right now
you can see I've got this little journal
here but if you're looking for some
really good tools Kevin Rose has a
podcast called the journal and he
interviewed this guy who is this savant
of accessible easy not easy to find but
relatively easy to find tools for
journaling so if you're really looking
for the great pen to use or or the best
notebook because for the type of ink
you're using it talks about it last
thing I'll talk about is Scrivener I on
my computer I use a software app called
Scrivener especially for writing books
and for a longer form essays it's a
great tool for organization and I think
you can you can just google that or if
we end up putting this up as a podcast
showing we can put it in the show notes
as well Scrivener is a good app to use
yeah but you don't need any app you
don't need a special pen yeah you don't
need special piece of paper like if you
want to write start writing if you're
waiting on the right program or the
right pen or the right piece of paper
then you'll always be waiting yes yeah
you'll never fight because you'll find
another excuse I'll tell you this so
this is along the same lines throughout
my 20s Ryan I was an aspiring writer and
that just means I didn't write very much
guys I aspired every single day I
aspired all over there's aspiration all
over it was disgusting it was a gross
amount of aspiration or aspiration a
type of perspiration a particular part
of your body could be alright anyway I
aspired a lot and I but that really
meant I wasn't doing the work I wasn't
willing to sit down and Drudge through
the drudgery which I realized I would
get excited about an idea but just
because I was excited about it as
not real passion real passion is being
willing to sit down day after day after
day put in the hours required to do the
work it's for writing I realized I
needed to actually start writing and I
always had all these excuses the reason
I was so aspiring all the time is I
would create these these I didn't call
them excuses it would be a to-do list
mmm I have to finish folding laundry I
have to make my cup of coffee I need to
have a cup of water I needed to do this
and that and this and this and then once
these 15 items are done then I'll be
able to start writing well of course I'd
end up getting the number thirteen or
fourteen two or three hours later and I
didn't have time for writing well my
time is up
guess I'll get to this tomorrow and the
thing about you know putting off to some
day some day never come some day is
always just around the bend and so I
realized I need to start doing it today
not some day turns some day into today
and it didn't matter the tools I had you
have the tools necessary to start
creating something meaningful if you
have a phone you can start recording a
podcast if you can buy it even we have
this microphone here in front of us it's
you know $100 microphone that we got
yeah it allows us to record podcasts our
friend Rob Bell started his podcast the
Rob cast he borrowed his son's dented
microphone and plugged it into his
computer couldn't even figure how to do
it they use QuickTime to record his at
first like 20 podcast episodes or
something and and the point is you don't
need all the tools you think you need to
get started you can just get started and
the other thing I'll encourage you to
take a look at is to dive deep into is
take a look at what Seth Godin writes
about creativity he has some some great
stuff out there about getting the work
done now shipping before it's ready
because it's never going to be ready if
you're waiting for the thing to be
perfect so Seth Godin has a daily blog
that he literally puts something every
single day of the year even on Christmas
Day without fail and he is a master a
Mozart of blogging I would encourage you
to check that out a lot of good creative
inspiration there all right let's do one
more Shawn
to travel how do you stay present and
not view the whole thing through the
viewfinder of a camera
yes yeah that's a great question well
you know I am NOT a hundred percent
against taking pictures I do we'll take
a shot here there but I will tell you
when the picture is ruining the moment I
will not pick up the phone and I wish I
could say I was like like I was obsessed
show and they opened up with noise and
I'm like trying to get a recording of it
uh-huh and I couldn't get a recording
and I'm like what are you doing dude
you're like totally ruining this mower
right now yeah like stuck it back in my
pocket and didn't get the recording but
uh but yeah I'd we definitely do avoid
you know taking a slew of pictures that
are just gonna sit somewhere in the
cloud the magical cloud yeah but I'll
tell you what we do to get the best out
of each city we visit because we like
especially in 2014 we went to 100
different cities we will first off look
for some really good coffee so we go way
out of our way to find a good coffee
shop and unfortunately there are some
cities that lake don't have good coffee
shops here's the cool thing so I've said
that before on a podcast we were in
Regina Saskatchewan Canada we find good
coffee there we did not yeah and I I
said something about it on the podcast
and then of course someone sent me a
tweet and said here are the three best
coffee shops and they all look amazing
nice we just couldn't yeah we couldn't
find whatever reason yeah so then what's
a good coffee we'll go and find a museum
like usually an art museum the like the
science museums there's like a little -
I don't know like there's a it's like
you know what a cool one occasion the
most Salt Lake it has a really awesome
sign it's pretty decent yeah I mean but
usually it's an art museum like Science
Museum's typically are like geared
towards children they often are and I do
have some great history and like some
good fossils and stuff but like yeah a
good art museum we will find some good
Thai food and if that's around but
typically that's what we're looking if
we got like two days to spend or three
days to spend in a place it's good
coffee good food and a cool Museum the
other thing I'll add to that is I'll try
to find a good independent bookshop in
quite often we were talking at them so
we don't have to go seek it out like we
found the good one that we want to go
speak at but
those four things that we just mentioned
are a great snapshot of a community if
you're just gonna spend a day or two
there in terms of taking pictures I did
an experiment I think for a year I wrote
about it in our book essential which is
an essay collection at 150 essays in
there and I think the title that I said
was something like why I don't take
photos during vacation and and it was
really about being present being in the
moment it was an experiment I did for a
while where I refused any time I went on
a vacation or traveling somewhere I
refused to take a photo and then what I
learned from that is I'd also didn't
want to deprive myself of taking a
snapshot at the moment I have a good
friend of ours Adam who is a
photographer and he is a very town of
photography took many of our pictures
early on for the website and he he was
talking about how he was considering he
was contemplating switching from digital
he had this nice digital camera take
Gregg takes great pictures to film
making the switch back to film because
it forced him to be more intentional
with the photos that he took great and
so as he's snapping shots he realized he
could just take one picture otherwise
he's wasting film so he better get the
best picture he can with this and even
if he doesn't then he has to move on to
the next thing he's gonna waste all his
film trying to capture the perfect
moment and I said well that's great but
you know I'm not gonna have my only
camera is my phone I have with rights so
but can't I employ that's that same
strategy with my phone and so quite
often when I go out and to a concert so
you're mentioned in sets that's a friend
of ours who's in a band called brother
Cephas down in Tampa Florida and you're
at their concert I was actually at their
concert and I took a photo it was the
only photo that I took one photo as if I
had a film camera I'm just gonna take
one so I don't waste this and so even if
it's messed up and it has a thumb or
it's blurry or whatever I hold on to it
I was at a Rob Bell event earlier
earlier this year and he was speaking
for a very long time I'm getting toward
the middle of it I'm like I'm gonna snap
one photo and like as I was taking this
one accidentally bumped the back of my
chair and so the photo is perfectly
blurry and I went ahead and posted on my
Instagram account anyway you can see it
a man at Joshua fields Melbourne on
Instagram
and it's a blurry photo and it's and I
tagged Rob Bela day because it was like
this this interesting sort of he was a
blur in the photo and I did a similar
thing although the photo didn't didn't
turn out as cool because it was actually
I was at a Sam Harris event the year
before that and Sam Harris so this is
interesting because Rob Bell's like this
religious figure sam Harris is that this
prominent atheist from an atheist figure
and I find value in both of their their
message I think we have all have similar
values by the way I'm not particularly
religious but I did the same thing in
the same Harris event and sort of
capture it in the you know sometimes you
accidentally put your thumb in a picture
well there's some back of their head was
in my picture I'm like well I'm not
gonna take another one I got the one
picture I said I would try to take and
I've captured the moment and I in that
one picture then gave me permission to
put the phone away and then be back in
the moment not-not-not try to keep
capturing the perfect moment I am going
to patent penned a cake a phone with a
camera on it that takes film all right
so that's all we got for this episode of
hashtag ask the minimalist live if you
have a question for us you can find us
on Twitter and Instagram at the
minimalists facebook.com slash the
minimalist you can also call in to our
podcast 406 two one nine seven eight
three nine Shawn if you do end up
putting this up as a podcast maybe this
is where we could paste some voicemail
messages tips and tricks from some of
our listeners hey guys my name is
Kristen I'm from Charleston South
Carolina and I just wanted to call in
and say that I've been listening to you
guys then a little after June of 2013
when at the time my husband and I were
living in Colorado Springs Colorado and
the black forest fire was going on at
that time and the evacuation zone was
right across the street from our house
so we were a little concerned that we
might have to evacuate
so I had a friend offer to run you store
some of my stuff at their house in case
we did have to evacuate in a hurry and I
wouldn't be scrambling to find somewhere
to put all my stuff it was important to
me so I took you know the important
things like document or certificate
paperwork and then out of all things
that I wanted to have them keep for me
or my clothes and of course being a
woman a lot of other women can probably
relate to this and the fact that we do
hold a lot of value in our clothing and
our giant beautiful wardrobe but I took
bags and bags of clothes over to my
friend's house and at the time I
actually afterwards I felt really crazy
and kind of embarrassed it that's what I
was taking over their house was just
bags of clothes so and my husband of
course thought it was ridiculous but we
did not end up having to evacuate which
was good and I got all my clothes back
and after that happened I started
researching ways to minimize my wardrobe
I just thought it was ridiculous that I
put so much into my clothes and why I
you know held such value in them hey
Joshua Ryan my name is Abraham
I'm from New Orleans Louisiana I want to
leave a comment about um something
that's working for me and I hope that it
worked for other people but I want to
let people know you talk about when you
go to a store to buy something and as
soon as that card swipes or as soon as
you hand to cashier your money
the feeling of goodness goes away well I
want to tell you that when I'm I'm
paying off me um me and my wife's death
right now working extra on long hours
working hard to be debt-free and it
seems like every single time that I drop
a couple extra hundred bucks on the debt
that we have it feels so good like
overleaf like that I've actually
accomplished something and I suggest
that everybody trying to take the
smallest debt that you have try your
best to do whatever you
yet to pick up extra hours at work to
pay it off paid off um you know just
take steps towards paying off and I
guarantee you the feelings of being free
from that debt there is no other feeling
that you magic hi this is Marc Sanders
from Littleton Colorado I just wanted to
share a funny story with you for your
podcast I've been working on
decluttering for the last about year or
so and I finally about a week ago got
rid of all of my schedule books from the
last 15 years uh it was kind of a
challenge for me to do that because I
had lots of notes written in there but
things that I didn't really need so I
finally made the decision to do it and
the night before that I was throwing
them out outside the bag broke and they
were all laying there right in front of
me again giving me another chance to
bring him back into the house so
sometimes clutter does fight back and
doesn't want to go but I was able to
pull myself together and throw them away
and haven't missed them at all alright
that that is it right now folks if you
leave here with one message we hope it
is this love people and use things
because the opposite never works thanks
for listening y'all we'll see you next
time
[Music]
every little thing you think that's me
every little thing you think that you
need every little thing that's just
feeding your green oh I bet that you'll
be fine without me
[Music]
every little thing that you got ahead
every little thing that you guys you
gotta reach for and you got a grand oh I
bet that you'll be fine without you
so chair your tea
[Music]
you
[Music]